[Music]
well for more than a century is statute
the University of North Carolina
commemorated alumni who died fighting
for the south in the Civil War since
then it has been frequently protested
it's remained standing and has itself
become a key part of campus history but
none of that means anything to the
modern left two nights ago a mob of
angry children trying out for Chairman
Mao's red guards apparently pulled the
statue down while law enforcement let
them do it
[Applause]
the point isn't how you feel about
Confederate statues a lot of reasonable
people think they're appalling they make
a strong case for that it doesn't matter
what she just saw is barbaric
and it's an attack on democracy itself
polls consistently show that Americans
believe the monument should be left
standing rather than change their minds
and you could make an argument and
change their minds the left doesn't want
to do that it uses the mob to get its
way and they keep doing it until the law
stands up to them which it these days
really does Bob Woodson is president and
founder the Woodson center and author of
the triumphs of Joseph and he joins us
tonight mr. Woodson thanks all for
joining us these would be his over I
assume you're not a supporter of
Confederate statues but tell me what you
think when you watch that video I'm
outraged that as a veteran of the Civil
Rights Movement
we fought to fulfill the dream of
America we supported our founding values
and our principles
we also didn't destroy anything in the
name of justice for those people out
there who are supposed to be heirs of
that legacy they are a fraud I'm against
taking those statues down to remember
something isn't meaning that you're
celebrating it the Jewish people brought
the Holocaust Museum because they said
it's important to remember it as a
Christian we remember the cross not
because it celebrates room and
oppression because it is victory over
death that we celebrate his resurrection
so it's important to apply your own
narrative to these symbols but I think
what is being done there is an outrage
and these are our anarchists they are
not freedom fighters and those of us who
are in a civil rights movement should
speak out against this outrage so you're
saying that having the statue up is not
a celebration of the Confederacy it's a
way for the rest of us to remember what
it was and the triumph over it by the
United States and that's right
and and it's also
just misused by members of the left to
really denigrate the values of this
nation that's that's what it is and
they're using race but what it does
Tucker also is to flex attention away
some of the more critical issues that we
are facing particularly in black America
where we have more blacks killed in one
year than were killed in 70 years
lynched in 70 years between 1873 and
1954 thousand blacks were lynched
brutally but six thousand blacks were
killed in one year and are taking a
Confederate statute down does nothing
for saving a life in Chicago but we're
talking about statues and not the
realities that are confronting thousands
of people who are losing their lives
today there's where we ought to be
putting our time and attention except
exactly and none of these people cares
at all mr. Whitson thank you very much
it's not our to have you tonight